se autoproclamó presidente la oposición
le apoyó también Estados Unidos y más de
50 países era enero de 2019 y Juan
guaidó amenazaba con quitarle el poder a
Nicolás Maduro pero el efecto se fue
diluyendo y finalmente la asamblea
nacional paralela vigente en la sombra
con los legisladores de 2015 ha decidido
acabar con el interinato Además del
reconocimiento internacional la
presidencia interina de guaidó consiguió
el control de cit go la filial Estatal
de petróleos de Venezuela en Estados
Unidos y obtuvo la legitimidad de 2.000
millones en oro del banco de Inglaterra
pero nunca consiguió culminar sus
promesas como convocar elecciones libres
o ejercer un poder real dentro de
Venezuela por el contrario los
escándalos de corrupción
erosionaron la credibilidad y ver una
nueva sobre todo elecciones de asamblea
nacional
independientemente que fuesen limpias o
no y una nueva asamblea nacional
sesionar en el hemiciclo eso bastante la
legitimidad porque es difícil mantener
la lógica del gobierno interino Un
gobierno que está diseñado para durar
días no años esto se produce en plenas
negociaciones entre el gobierno de
maduro y la oposición con las elecciones
de 2024 como telón de fondo y con un
acercamiento internacional a maduro
desde su homólogo colombiano Gustavo
Petro pasando por Estados Unidos ya está
Emanuel macron presidente de Francia y
la la búsqueda de muchos estados de
pasar la página no quiere decir que
ellos no apoyen un cambio en Venezuela
no implica que no apoyen elecciones
libres pero sí significa que el
mecanismo de Gobierno interino ya no
funcionaba para ellos
las elecciones de 2018 en las que
Nicolás Maduro fue reelegido fueron
rechazadas en bloque por la oposición
momento en el que emergió Juan guaidó y
casi cuatro años después esa estrategia
finalmente ha terminado
[Aplausos]